6 26 now on your monday morning we're
talking about bicycles and
wheelchairs we've talked a lot recently
about bicycles and cars
and the sometimes tragic interactions
between them well today viewer keith has
a different problem he writes
why are the rules about bicycles riding
on sidewalks not enforced those of us in
wheelchairs he writes
shouldn't be even more inconvenienced
trying to avoid a collision he says
there's enough obstacles we have to
avoid as it is well keith
i checked in with tony capsudo he's the
vice president of the southern nevada
bicycle coalition and he told me
the question really touches a nerve with
him
i happen to have two step kids with
special needs
so we've experienced ourselves in the
past some of the challenges
that people face uh when they're trying
to get around
in a wheelchair whether it's a sidewalk
being
wide enough to accommodate you know
somebody in a wheelchair
and an additional pedestrian going the
other way we encourage
people to take the safest routes
possible and as part of our safe routes
campaign
that doesn't include riding your bicycle
on the sidewalk
tony says the legality of riding bikes
on sidewalks
varies from city to city but his group
favors
roads or bike paths keith thanks for
writing tony
thanks to you and snvbc president rob
hutchinson
for everything your group is doing to
promote safe bicycling
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone if there's something
driving you crazy email me traffic eight
at eightnewsnow.com